and in other local news this morning  we're launching a new series with the  Kahn Academy an online education  platform in the videos I talked civics  and history with the nonprofit's founder  or some Casal Kahn when Thomas Jefferson  wrote the Declaration of Independence he  said this new country that we're  creating has to constantly refresh each  new generation has to refresh their  contact with the original ideals that  the country was founded on otherwise the  country will fail and so it's not only  important to know what's going on around  us by studying history but it is  according to Thomas Jefferson your duty  to stay engaged with the ideas of  America so that those ideas don't get  lost in the kind of flurry and craziness  of a current moment when we discuss  subjects ranging from the presidency to  the Supreme Court series is for students  or anyone else who's interested in how  government works to watch go to  khanacademy.org